when you discover who you are then
everything else is going to fall into
place are these going to be like I feel
for sure that this was my life purpose
like discovering the secret and doing
everything that I'm doing I know for
sure this is what I was meant to do so
there is that aspect too but don't lose
sight of finding out who you are that is
so important because the person comes
and goes but the infinite being that you
are awareness Consciousness is eternal
when you've got that one young Pat and
you're living your life as that well
then oh because you can do whatever you
want because you will have an amazing
incredible life with career fair and
free of all negativity all negative
thoughts all negative emotions all
problems you'll just have a great life
need motivation what the dog stands We
Believe Nation hey it's Evan Carl
Michael and I make these videos because
you are probably the most ambitious
person in your circle but you know
you're capable of more and you get that
Push by surrounding yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best Rhonda Byrne and my take on her
top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two be peaceful and calm
when I discovered the sacred I was just
I really really trained that monkey mind
to be positive positive positive and
um and so completely changed my life by
just changing my mind and the way that I
thought
to but still there were times and
situations that arose where that I I
would get completely Disturbed in this
emotion would just rush over me negative
emotion will rush over me and it's all
all through welcoming through through
discovering who we really are
and through welcoming all of the things
in the greater sacred actually
and now I pretty well live my life in
calm and peaceful in every situation
and and you can do it you can have that
life and if you are calm and peaceful
you're happy you're happy all the time
and so there aren't many things that
disturb my peace of mind anymore and
because we don't really I think we've
put it in the Greatest Secret
um we're not looking for peace of mind
we're looking for a piece from mind
well we really that's the truth so
yeah so when you understand who you are
who you really are and
and then you start to have a happiness
just arise within you then you just find
that person that used to annoy you just
doesn't annoy you anymore and you'll be
like
get on really well with that person I
what what was it that ever bothered me
about that person or or the restaurant
that you never really like to go to and
when you go to it you're like
why didn't I like this restaurant this
restaurant is so cool I mean they've got
this new menu and I don't know what you
can I don't know what was wrong with me
I've completely changed nothing will
affect you in the way that affects you
anymore and and you know everything in
life traffic jam
it's just you know when you get caught
in traffic do you know what the universe
is telling you
and just be still just stop and be still
and become and be peaceful that's what
it's telling you everything is a gift
absolutely everything rule number three
activate your healing power how can you
activate your self-healing and help your
body heal while feeling the discomfort
in your body
and you know It's Tricky isn't it
because the body has all of its
Sensations and it kind of keeps
reminding you there's this little thing
going on you know what I'm going to do
I'm going to give you something that I
do each day and I'm going to give you
this and also remember the super open
affirmations
so
you need to visualize what yourself well
and I'll tell you what I do what I've
done in the past is that I close my eyes
and I just imagine that I am outside on
a lawn and that I am jumping for joy and
I and I'm going yes yes yes
that whatever it was has completely
disappeared so that is
um that is visualizing or you can
visualize a phone call with somebody
that you're really close to like your
mum for example and you're like guess
what mum it's gone it's disappeared and
just visualize that phone call until the
subconscious mind gets a hold of it and
then you're going to find
you will be attracted to what will have
it disappear and it will just disappear
um but in the meantime I want to give
you and you've got this recording okay
so you'll be able to go back and write
these down but these are just some
affirmations that are really powerful
that that's for your body so I allow my
body to heal itself
I allow my body to have perfect health
I allow Perfection to manifest in this
body now
I am happy happy
I am healthy healthy healthy I am well I
am well I am well I am amazingly healthy
thank you thank you thank you for my
perfect health and well-being
so those affirmations are really really
powerful your body okay and for anybody
out there for anything that you might be
suffering from when it doesn't matter
whether it's something big whether it's
something small whether it's something
that's just irritating or
um those affirmations are really amazing
rule number four practice welcoming
feelings in The Greatest Secret we used
it and there's an analogy about a bird
flying by it was actually to do with
thought I think if I recall that if a
bird is flying by we don't we don't ask
the bird well where are you from what
what what breed of bird are you where
did you come from where you're going to
um you know you just nested if you've
got a partner where's the rest of your
family I mean we don't get involved with
that bird do we we just let the bird fly
on by and that's what we should do with
thoughts and actually feelings it's not
a bad idea it's just let them pass by
because all that they are is energy and
if we just let them pass on by AI then
they don't stick to us and they don't
stay and they don't impact our life
um also if we are observing feelings
we're welcome welcoming feelings and
I've talked about welcoming before
welcoming is a process that stops us
from resisting and so because resistance
is really the one thing that gets in the
way of manifestation is that we're
resisting and resistance it's like doubt
and I don't really believe that I'm
going to get it all of those does that's
just resistance that's all it is and so
when we welcome something that causes us
to stop resisting and the way that we
welcome is we just get that feeling that
negative feeling and we just allow that
negative feeling to be here we don't
resist it we don't try and push it away
we just allow it to be here and it will
just dissolve It's Just Energy and it
will just spiral and dissolve and be
completely gone and your life just got a
whole lot better from doing that and so
welcoming stops resistance and so and so
that means that you're not identifying
with the feeling and you're not
believing the feeling because nothing's
personal you know those feelings they're
Just Energy they're not personal like
they don't have your name on them you
think that too but they don't and
thoughts don't have your name on uh have
your name on them either they're Just
Energy we could say Just Energy passing
by like clouds you know so
um
so yeah that's I mean that's the sacred
isn't it is to not believe negative
thoughts and negative feelings if we
could just do that life would be great
and you don't have to you don't have to
try and control them
you're starting to like them right and
you might and there might be a really
juicy thought or a juicy feeling that
comes in and and you kind of ride in
that feeling like a roller coaster for a
few hours and then when you've suffered
enough from that awful feeling you just
you just think I've had enough and then
you realize oh no I was identifying with
that feeling I thought that that feeling
was who I am because do you know what
what happens like guilt for example
guilt the energy of guilt can just be
like passing by just passing through
except when it passes through we can say
we can say
I'm guilty
but I know that was just guilt nothing
to do with us also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five reject negative
thoughts when we reject the negative
thought are we creating resistance
we could be it depends how you're
rejecting it if you just if you're just
kind of letting it go and not
identifying with it and not believing it
then it's not going to create any
resistance but if you wish it wasn't
there and if you wanted to go away and
you fall like that about it then you are
creating existence and the next part of
Leslie's question is to welcome a
negative thought stops resistance that's
true but are we manifesting that
negative thought and letting it into our
subconscious by welcoming it are we
manifesting the negative thought when we
welcome a negative thought
so no it won't manifest and the reason
it won't manifest is because we're not
believing it because when we welcome it
we've noticed what it is we're not
believing it we're not identifying with
it and it won't manifest thoughts only
manifest when we believe them when we
identify with them so welcoming not only
releases the negative thought it takes a
whole lot of negative thoughts out of
the subconscious mind with it so I mean
it's all it's a really incredible my
teacher would say it's an automatic
self-cleansing mechanism
so all we have to do is just kind of
welcome that negative thought or welcome
that negative feeling and it's basically
cleaning out everything and as it does
you get lighter your life becomes
spectacular you become so happy nothing
bothers you anymore you don't even
understand what the word problems means
it's some alien word that other people
must experience but you don't see a
problem with anything anywhere unlike is
just incredible and your body feels
amazing so
um so it's worth it yeah it's worth it
but you are not going to manifest that
thought
um when you are welcoming it rule number
six let go of attachments to desires you
just have to let go of all the
attachments to your desires okay
when we let go of all our attachments to
desires guess what happens all our
desires manifest because when we don't
have attachment to our desires we don't
have resistance
and so I don't know that
I I try to think if I have if I have
many desires anymore I just love
everything the way life is just the way
it is even the tricky stuff even the
curly stuff even the sticky stuff it's
all just kind of fine but I don't have
an attachment to the way it's going to
work out because I know that everything
is fine I know we're all safe I know
we're Eternal I know there's no end to
any of us I know we're having an
adventure we're having a human
experience
and it's interesting at times isn't it
and it's fantastic at other times I
actually look at the world and I think
it's incredible I really think it's
something else
um but I don't get so perturbed I don't
get perturbed by all of those things
it's just anymore and so if you don't
have attachment
um to things then can life is really
really great actually
um attachments that kind of hurt us
um okay Jill is saying what do you mean
by attachment to your desires okay
so attachment is like when I really
really want something and I've really
really got to have it it's something
that you really really want and I've
really got to have it and I want it and
I can't be happy until I have it I just
life isn't going to be good until I have
it that's like an attachment to your
desire whereas if you were like
um
wouldn't it be
wouldn't it be nice wouldn't it be nice
to have a new house
okay so here's the difference I really
really want a new house I can't stand
this house this house is falling down
this house has a lot of problems and
then
on the other side of that is wouldn't it
be nice wouldn't it be nice to have a
new house
Can You Feel the difference this one has
is effortless it's kind of effortless
wouldn't it be nice so you could say
that in front of all of you all of your
um desires wouldn't it be nice if I had
this wouldn't it be nice and so that
you're not kind of attached
because when you're attached it's really
hard for it to manifest okay
so in the greater sacred I talk about
attachment
um I do a whole section on it and I do
it because it's important
um because you can have whatever you
want but attachment is something
attachment is
attachment is full of fear
fear that you're not going to have it
um uh you you can love somebody
and then you can be attached that you'll
be afraid of losing them you say love
isn't afraid of anything
attachment is afraid of losing
losing something
so that's kind that's kind of the
difference but if you if you just say
wouldn't it be nice you know then it's
like really easy going I mean you've got
a magic wand you can create anything you
want but you just got to be really cool
about it right you got to be I can do
that I can have that I can be that rule
number seven believe what you visualize
I want you to know that there's not
really any difference between you
walking around in this world here this
is for Law of Attraction no difference
to that or you imagining in your mind
there's no difference it doesn't know
any difference between the two so if
you're if you're visualizing it Law of
Attraction for Law of Attraction this is
something that you you already have
and and so if you're not really
believing it it it just kind of means
you need to do it some more right and um
and and try and come up with some
scenarios that are really believable to
you like one of the things I would
always do to manifest and I don't know
why it just worked for me I defaulted to
this I would I would imagine I would
imagine telling somebody what I
manifested that it had already
manifested so I would imagine those
phone calls I would imagine talking to a
friend I would imagine people saying you
know saying to me wow how did you get
that where did you get that so that was
really believable to me but if because
if you really want something then you're
going to want to share it with family
and friends and and so that really
worked incredibly well for me so maybe
that might work for you give that a try
rule number eight stop comparing with
others in The Greatest Secret
uh it is explained that there's only
three kinds of thoughts and they are
comparing describing and measuring every
single thought you have fits into one of
those three categories and all Minds
behave this way all minds are comparing
measuring and describing every single
one of us we're not unique you know
we're not unique we've all we've all got
the same Smorgasbord of thoughts to to
kind of play with
um so but but the thing is it doesn't
with those thoughts it doesn't matter
what the Mind does
what matters is that you don't believe
those thoughts right you just you don't
want to identify with those thoughts and
don't believe them you don't need to
control them be trying to bash them down
with a hammer go go no you don't have to
do any of that you just need to be
observing and witnessing them and that's
the moment that you observe a thought
you were no longer identified with that
thought or believing that thought and it
can't manifest you just like stock
manifestation in its tracks for a
negative thought so it's really perfect
um The More You observe and don't
believe thoughts the quieter your mind
will become
um and I talked before about thoughts
are not personal so they you know
they're just looking for someone to
energize them and just say be on your
way you're not you don't belong here I'm
fabulous I'm the infinite being I don't
want any I don't want any negative
thoughts be on your way rule number nine
overcome limiting beliefs for anybody
who has any belief that they don't want
like for example
unlimited there are only a certain
number of things that I can do
[Music]
um I can't do I can't do that I can't do
anything that I want I can't have
anything that I want I can't be anything
that I want if you have if you have any
of those beliefs then you could do this
too so
all you need to do is welcome the belief
that you don't want and for this person
this is what you're really going to find
interesting
is that this person says that they have
a belief that they're finding it
difficult to manage one strong belief
that if I miss an opportunity which
matters a lot to me then it takes years
to get another opportunity so the belief
that the person has is if I miss an
opportunity which matters a lot to me
right and so what I want you to do and I
wish I could say your name but it's
maherto forum
whatever that is okay
um so what I want you to do
and this is what my teacher would say to
me welcome wanting to miss opportunities
that matter a lot to you
and you're like what
but if you welcome
wanting to miss opportunities that
matter a lot to you and then welcome the
feelings that you have of wanting to
regress and welcome any feelings of
regression now that seems totally
contradictory right but let me explain
because it's not why would you want to
miss opportunities that matter a lot to
you well actually
the fact that you have a belief of that
means that somehow
somehow you have thoughts that got into
your subconscious mind that formed a
belief and you know that otherwise you
wouldn't have this belief at all and so
you definitely have it your subconscious
mind thinks you want this thinks you
want it it's got it all wrong but it got
some thoughts in it and it just accepted
it and it was maybe when you were a
child or you heard somebody say
something and you just accepted it and
so that's how we know that we need to
take this belief out and if you welcome
wanting to miss opportunities that
matter a lot to you if you welcome it
you release it
you release it so welcoming is just like
opening up like this welcoming with your
arms out kind of like this
and just welcoming that
and when you welcome that you are
releasing that belief
so incredible really it's so easy it's
worth the effort it really is worth it
because
any negative subject any negative
feelings any belief that you don't want
that's it that's the one practice that's
why it's in The Greatest Secret in my
latest book The Greatest Secret this is
the most important thing you could ever
do I've been doing it now for since I
met my teacher which was in 216
2016 I just don't have I can't even find
a belief I'd love to find one I'd love
to find one because I'd love to get it
you know but uh uh so everything that
we're experiencing is because somehow
our subconscious mind thinks we want it
incredible right there are some things
we don't want at all but our
subconscious mind thinks we do want it
we have inadvertently believed something
so that's why you welcome wanting
something you absolutely don't want
because you're releasing the hidden
beliefs that are causing it you see
it's interesting isn't it it's kind of a
reverse
uh but it's what you have to do with the
subconscious mind and and you can kind
of um
I wish I could remember an instance
where my teacher said to me
um it'll count one will come to me I I
remember talking to her and she would
say welcome uh I would say oh I don't I
don't like the feeling of fear and she
would say welcome wanting the feeling of
fear and I'd be like no I don't want it
she's like no you have to welcome not
wanting her because look no I don't want
it you're pushing it away and guess what
you're going like that you're not going
like that you're going like that and
you're pushing it down inside of you
super gluing up to you and Rule Number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is shift your perspective
from the perspective of the person okay
we will be afraid of leaving the people
we love from the perspective of the
person which is the mind and the ego
will be afraid of dying okay
but from the perspective of the infinite
being that you are which is awareness
you can never be afraid of anything
and you will never be afraid of leaving
anyone because you know
that you can never be separated from
anyone ever
because we are one
you will never be separated from anyone
and so from the perspective of the
infinite being who knows that everything
is perfect
that everything is just fine that body's
end but we do not end
uh there is no fear at all and so what's
really tricky is if you are trying to
get the person not to be afraid or the
ego and the mind not to be afraid and
and trying to get the ego mind not to be
afraid of leaving people behind you're
never going to do it okay it's never
going to happen because the ego in the
mind the ego is afraid of dying always
going to be that's why you want to get
off the ego boat and get on to the
infinite Bingo right it's the infinite
being the infinite being knows
everything is fine and is always joyful
and is always happy I don't want to go I
don't want to go I don't want to go and
leave you guys
everything is possible you know when you
believe that's
the kind of kicker you have to believe
but it's not that hard it's really
pretty easy
our belief
creates our entire life experience and
so you can't if I put it this way you
can't experience anything in life
that is outside of your own beliefs
so and that's that's the case for every
single one of us we really can't
experience anything that's outside of
our beliefs if we can't experience
anything that's outside of our beliefs
what that means is look at all those
hearts that's so beautiful
what that means is there's not really
one world we kind of think there's one
world but there isn't really because
we're all experiencing a world based on
our beliefs and not one of us has the
same beliefs not one of us so that means
there's a different world for every one
of us
so all of your beliefs
are held in your subconscious mind and
the subconscious mind is just a part of
your mind there's the conscious mind and
then there's the subconscious mind
there's actual which is actually higher
than the conscious mind and so we use
our conscious mind with all of the
thoughts and everything that we have our
conscious mind is very present right and
so
to create anything
you are using your subconscious mind
your subconscious mind is what is really
what creates if I want to make it really
really simple then I would say the
subconscious mind is what creates
it makes things appear and manifest
things and that's where all of your
beliefs are stored kind of neat huh
because you have to believe to manifest
something and your subconscious mind
creates everything so you can see it's
all kind of perfectly designed
so now to manifest you have to believe
and you have to believe that you already
have whatever it is that you want and
the reason that you have to believe you
have it already is because the
subconscious mind is only operating in
the present it can't reason it's just
like a program so if you say for example
um a new car is coming my new car is
coming I'm going to get a new car it's
coming well then it's always going to be
coming right that's the that's the thing
you have to imagine you have it now you
have to go off and you have to test
drive the car you've got to feel the car
smell the car and just then visualize
being in that car and then when you do
that that's how
if you do that enough that's how you'll
come to believe that you actually have
the car and the moment that you believe
there's manifestations instantaneous
so so the other ways to believe is to
affirm over and over and over
um so to be really repetitive for
example
um to visualize and visualizing is
incredibly powerful because when we
close our eyes and we put ourselves in
the picture and you must make sure
you're in the picture and you put
yourself in the picture with whatever it
is that you want and you close your eyes
and you just kind of create this mini
movie honestly
the subconscious mind does not know that
you're imagining it has no idea it just
sees that movie and recreates it it's
like a giant photocopying machine it
will just whatever you hold in your mind
it will
photocopy it warm into the world so
um so if you are thinking about
something in the future it's always
going to be in the future so you have to
imagine that you have it now you have to
act as if and for example
if you wanted to attract a perfect
partner are you acting as if your
perfect partner's here already and so
there are just small things that you can
do that are super super powerful for
example are you sleeping in the middle
of your bed or are you sleeping on one
side of the bed because your partner's
on the other side of the bed
do you have room in your wardrobe for
your perfect partner's clothes is there
room in your bathroom for their
toothbrush and for their things and so
you see they are just little things you
can set the table for two you don't have
to put food on the plate but just
setting the table for two is really
really powerful it's saying my perfect
partner's here already and the
subconscious mind will believe it and
your perfect partner will be attracted
to you through the most incredible
circumstances so if something hasn't
manifested yet and you really really
want it and I I doubt there's anybody
out there who's who wants something and
it has a manifested right I mean
um I'll tell you the reason why it
hasn't manifested is because you don't
believe you have it doubt this comes
from the mind
and they're just thoughts and and
they're the reason that they're
appearing is because you have a belief
that is saying that you don't have this
already but just don't give those doubts
any any energy and work harder on
feeling that you have your manifestation
because when you believe you have your
manifestation no thoughts of Doubt will
come when you believe you have it you
have overridden any other belief in the
subconscious mind you've reprogrammed
your subconscious and then it will
manifest so just remind yourself that
you are the power
that creates everything
honestly effortlessly you were that
power so so just
take it it's not it's not an effort it's
really easy you know it's really easy
just take it easy let go of the let go
of the doubtful thoughts the welcoming
practice sounds counter-intuitive that
you would welcome something right that
you don't want it's like whoa hang on a
minute that doesn't make any sense it
does when I explain this to you is that
what when something that we don't want
appears we resist it
and if you remember in the secret what
you resist persists and so if you're
resisting something you don't want it
will never go away
welcoming is the opposite to resisting
welcoming stops you from resisting
that's why it's so brilliant
because resistance is
not bad really but
even that idea of resistance not being
Fab is something to welcome that thought
is something to welcome and just welcome
that thought and then that thought
will completely dissolve instead of
building up inside of you and the mind
saying yeah resistance isn't any good
yeah you know the mind adding a whole
lot of other thought a whole lot of
other thoughts so that's a perfect
example of welcoming now what I did just
then because I've welcomed for the last
four years what I did just then I felt
it completely dissolve in my chest that
thought I the feeling that was behind
that thought just completely dissolved
and now that is gone
so it's it's it's that easy how do we
break that negative thought pattern
right so so you I mean the mind is like
a computer program so and and the fact
that it's on a negative Loop is because
we programmed it on a negative Loop but
but you know we could have been
influenced from our children and things
like that so
um so one of the things that the Mind
loves is loves repetition I mean loves
it you know if you really watch your
thoughts this is the same old thoughts
over and over again you know it's just
kind of dishing up the same old thing so
it loves repetition so the way you can
override a program is to put in the
opposite you know and when you start out
you know you feel like you're lying you
know you'll say something like you know
you might be really broke gee I was when
I was making the secret so
um you might not have any money and
you're trying to instill you know wealth
and prosperity and riches and every time
you say it you feel a contraction in
your body because you know you don't
have it but you know truly because I did
it myself after a while you change it
you you really begin to change it and
you don't quite have that contraction
anymore and then you start to see money
coming in you know in in different ways
um and and and or you can be given
things that you were going to buy and
now you don't have to buy it or so you
begin to see you start to see signs of
land you know is one of the great one of
the great new thought thought writers
would say talk about a sign of land so
you start to see sign of land now that's
what I did in the secret you can do
gratitude that will turn everything
around that will make you feel good that
will get you off the negative rant but
those negative thoughts are coming from
beliefs held in the subconscious mind
right that's where the beliefs stem from
for most of us they stem mostly from our
childhood
conditioning yeah somebody's our parents
said something to us we just swallowed
it pork lion and zinker you know we're
like right that's a belief and uh and so
we take it in and and then we have all
these beliefs that that uh and you can
hear you know if you if you're talking
to somebody like if if somebody says oh
I believe
or because we say that all the time or
somebody says I think
behind those two
behind those two statements are going to
be a belief and so the really
interesting thing they're hard to spot
because you believe they're true
yeah you don't think they're a belief
you think they're real you know and so
they can be hard to spot but if you
start to listen to yourself you know I
believe or I think or especially look at
the things that you have really strong
opinion about
because where you have a really strong
opinion is a belief that's underneath
that
so so one of the things that in the
latest book is that I show how to
um show how to dissolve those those
beliefs and just really by some of the
things that I've just mentioned and uh
and and you can dissolve them and you
just feel free every time a belief goes
out you feel completely free you know
it's it's amazing amazing feeling to you
just feel as light as a feather and
actually you feel invincible so when you
think a deliberate thought of what you
want
um then Law of Attraction will employ
the universe and all people
circumstances and events to move you to
what you've asked for and to move what
you've asked for to you and so if if if
you think about that there is just
action would be really really hard for
you to reach all of the people's
circumstances and events manipulate all
of them to receive what you want and if
you really reflect well on your life and
things that have happened in your life
you'll kind of see that
actually that happened for me all I did
was moved here or all I did was move to
there and I received what I wanted
thought creates all of the appearances
in the world and thought creates
everything in your life
so it's pretty darn powerful right and
what you think about is what you get
what you focus on is what will manifest
in your life and everyone is manifesting
their day every single day we're doing
it
um we are not aware of course
necessarily of thoughts but thoughts
come we energize them and then they will
manifest unless we cancel that thought
out
um with another thought whether thought
that contradicts it but I remember
Lester Levinson would say every single
thought manifests and I just thought
that was incredible I had known the
secret for years and years and years and
Lester Levinson was a real master
and he said every single thought
manifests and others as wow
that's how powerful they are so
so thoughts are your superpower
to be do and have
what you want to experience and have and
do in your life
and and so if you ask
um an athlete or if you talk to a coach
a really brilliant coach right of a
sports team then you will find that
visualization and these principles that
I'm talking about are a big part of
their training that they have to be they
have to see themselves winning the game
they have to see themselves winning the
match there is a really incredible
tennis player that's a very big fan a
um a champion tennis player that's a
really big fan of the secret who uses
the sacred this is what he does he sees
that he has won the match before he
walks out onto that court and and it's
the same for
um for teams it's the same for athletes
in the Olympic Games running a race and
seeing that they've won yes they run the
race but
what has them win the race is that they
saw themselves winning before they even
got on the starting block and they saw
it and believed it and felt it and so
they just everything lined up for them
in the perfect way they drew the perfect
Lane everybody else was was moved in
exactly the right position and they got
a really great start and they won the
race and so thought history was so so
powerful so athletes but also do you
know the astronauts in the Apollo
um program did visualization before they
went to the moon and they visualized
Landing back on Earth safely and so
that's how important the visualize that
visualization is just thought in
pictures by the way it's it's it still
thought it's just the same thing okay
it's just thought in pictures
so if you took a person who had zero
resistance
and you lock them in a room you know if
you took a person that had zero
resistance that person thought about
what they wanted zero resistance lock
them in a room what they wanted will
come to them
the universe will move people
circumstances and events and bring that
right to them in math they absolutely
must because if you have no resistance
you have Unleashed a law that just
cannot be stopped and so you will
manifest it will come to you they had
this belief that I did not have an
abundant amount of money and uh that I
was always in struggle and that came
from my parents bless them you know they
are beautiful
um but that that came from them you know
we can't afford it and all of those
things so I was brought up with that as
many of us are so the the one one that I
had the biggest thing to overcome the
belief the biggest thing to overcome was
the belief in lack of money and and I
knew I needed to overcome that for the
secret to sweep the world all the things
I was going to buy you know when the
money came in
um so I did all of these lists and I'm
imagine that I had those things already
and yeah and I wanted I remember it was
like I want a house on the ocean I
really went all out you know that was
just some list one of the things I
remember is that I'd always wanted to
arrange for over all of my life and that
was just beyond anything I could afford
and especially in Australia like they
were crazy prices so but still I put it
on the list and I put all these things
on the list but you know interestingly
enough like I did that because that was
a way to turn money around
but when the sacred got released I
didn't care about any of it because and
I didn't even care all that mattered was
that I had got it out into the world and
now it was in the world it could never
be taken away and that is what mattered
to me more than anything is that that
was going to get into people's hands and
so
um but still I have to tell you got all
the things on the list you know it was
amazing views out here of the ocean
um I ended up by getting a Range Rover
um and so yeah but I did I did a lot of
practices the best thing that could
happen to everybody is that their
greatest dream comes true
because when your greatest dream comes
true the dream that where you are
absolutely convinced that when this
dream comes true that is when I will
really be happy the best thing that can
happen is that dream comes true because
when it does you will realize that there
is something missing and that happiness
that you thought you would have doesn't
last and so it's you know it's it's such
a beautiful thing and for people who
have been successful then they get to
that point and they're like they're not
happy and they're not happy because
those things were never going to make
you happy in the first place anyway and
so um but in terms of success
I would say this that
when you are who you really are when
you're living from the place more of who
you are than who you are not
everything that you need and want will
fall into your hands effortlessly and
you are actually the infinite being is
effortless
and the way to kind of tell who's in
charge is whether it's the ego or the
mind that's in charge or or who you
really are that is in charge in any
moment is effort and if you're efforting
if you can feel this efforting then it's
the ego in the mind and if you're coming
from a place of effortlessness where
athletes call it being in the flow and
everybody has these kind of descriptions
it's where the mind has stopped and just
everything is Flowing us you just feel
like everything in the universe is just
dancing your dance and singing to your
song and so in terms of success when you
are being more of Who You Are
that idea that was going to make you
successful is what will come to you that
original idea because the mind just
recycles that's all it can do it's a
program and recycles and the ideas that
business kind of business ideas that
have never been on Earth they are coming
from awareness they are coming from
above the vine so when you are awareness
that is when everything will fall into
your hands everything that you need and
it just your whole life flows and you're
just happy all of the time I love going
with the flow
I really do because I have found that
life will present to me
manifestations far greater than I could
ever imagine with my mind and so I'm
really just these days letting
everything go because life does a way
better job than me of I can't even think
of things that that are more fantastic
than what life does in my latest book
The Greatest Secret
the most important practice in that book
without a doubt is welcoming negative
emotions because
when you welcome any negative emotion
you are dissolving it from within your
body from within the subconscious mind
the next time say for example if it was
anger the next time you feel anger it's
not nearly as bad you welcome again the
time after that it's reducing reducing
until
it's not possible for you to feel anger
anymore
and with that anger gone from your body
your body the health of your body is
working brilliantly but two you will
just manifest like you can't believe
like just a single little flimsy thought
and it will manifest so getting rid of
negative emotions also negative emotions
are covering over your basic nature
which is happiness and all of this I
explain in The Greatest Secret I explain
it all in here
um and so yeah it's your it's your basic
nature so negative emotions are covering
up your happiness so to get rid of those
emotions is really really important so
now I wanted to explain that to
everybody who doesn't know about the
welcoming process
and now let me explain the welcoming
process to you what we tend to do with
negative emotions is we tend to resist
them so don't feel good right and so we
want to push them away we don't want to
feel them we don't want to feel fear we
don't want to feel disappointment
impatience and anger and so we'll push
them away we think we're pushing them
away but in actual fact we're pushing
them down here into our body into the
subconscious mind and they act like a
pressure cooker they're causing harm to
the body but they also act like a
pressure cooker in that they need to
release some energy to sow that because
they're just about to burst and so
they'll find something in the world an
emotion will find something in the world
to get angry about to release the
pressure in your body and so welcoming
is the opposite to resisting you're
pushing them away now you're not going
to do that now you're going to welcome
the negative emotion so when a negative
emotion arises basically what you're
going to do is kind of do nothing you
know really
um welcoming is just stopping us from
resisting what I do is I imagine that
that emotion is a really really good
friend of mine and I'm just allowing it
to be here I'm allowing it to be here in
the body and I just imagine that it's a
friend and I put my arms around it and
as you welcome it or allow it to be here
something absolutely incredible happens
it just dissolves it just dissolves and
in that moment you have managed to get
rid of a whole lot of that negative
emotion in your body and so that's why
this is the most incredible process
because a you will get happier and
happier B every desire you've ever
wanted will be fulfilled and say you
will have the most incredible life a
life free of fear
and um and knowing who you are and
understanding the incredible power you
have in the world so just imagine that
it's you have a friend and you're
putting your arms around a friend that
is how I do it but also too something
you can do is I'll just make sure you
can see my arms what you can do is just
open your arms up like this because
opening your arms like this sort of
opens the whole chest area and that
automatically makes you stop resisting
right and you open like this and you
will feel that negative emotion dissolve
for all of us you know and we've been
conditioned you know I mean you were
very fortunate because you you had a a
childhood where
you were mind was opened and you were
opened and your heart was opened and
that's the biggest biggest thing is to
open yourself after the possibility that
everything isn't the way it appears to
be and so even if you can just open
yourself to that possibility just for a
moment you can pick up it all the next
day you can take it all with you the
next day that it's all real and
everything that you're seeing but if you
just for a moment open to the
possibility that things might not be the
way that you think they are then you
have the greatest opportunity to really
discover something incredible how
incredible you are
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to watch
my recent one-on-one sit down with Gabby
Bernstein check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there trauma is very delicate and we all
have it you rip off the Band-Aid too
fast you'll get blown out
it'll be too too scary at once we all
have the capacity to be of service to
others